Oh
Oh
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
[Music]
Oh
Oh
ah
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
Oh
[Music]
[Applause]
applause this cheap virtuosity is very
expensive I know you didn't expect this
but you know Chopin and there's not
enough Chopin in our program and I want
to get in a lot but Chopin in his
funeral mark synodic you know can you
start from the the funeral march that we
all know that every mafia member is
buried to it in every movie but in the
last the last movement his love of bah
or he's the only man of his time that
actually knew box so well that he had
memorized physically all of the preludes
and few of the well-tempered clavier and
he you'll hear the Bach influence I
don't know if you can do this but play
the last movement after the funeral
marks which they call the wind over the
graves the right hand alone because this
is a unison this piece is so hard I'm
sure even for you Barbara and listen
listen to this right hand right hand
alone play it it's so just play it
slowly very gruesome very harmonically
unbelievable
for all new harmonies it's a cherdon
Berg already if you play its but now
play the left hand now what this is so
incredible about in white pianist and
the greatest performance is Russell on
and off by the way sorry play the left
hand and you will see that it's the same
notes exactly try to do that
[Music]
it's very beautiful slow all Chopin left
hands are beautiful slow alright now I
don't know if you can do it but go as
far as you can because it's really
interesting to see the fact that this
part of virtuosity the left hand had
never been developed I mean heightened
did this you know others just like you
know no concept of virtuosity yet now I
play this together
do it fast see where you go
[Music]
break
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
[Music]
Oh
[Applause]